what all right look H what is going on
over there all right seriously Lucasfilm
what are you doing like I'm not I'm not
even talking about like the direction of
the Star Wars thing anymore this isn't
me complaining about narrative this is
just business-wise what are you doing
okay so news broke earlier this week
that the two guys who did the game of
Thrones
show that the head the showrunners on
that Ben anathan Weiss they had
previously signed a deal to work on a
trilogy of Star Wars films now they're
off that and we learned some more
details about that which just makes it
just kind of makes everybody look bad I
know I opened going Lucasfilm what are
you doing but also like these guys okay
so a recap for everybody um the two guys
who ran Game of Thrones again Benioff
and Weiss they had sign to do three Star
Wars films and the pitch that they have
was do a trilogy of basically about the
creation of the Jedi as an order which I
mean that's that's about as solid a
pitch as any it's a prequel technically
but it's so far removed from the
narrative of the other stuff it kind of
frees you up a little bit more to do
other things in theory at least now they
they were already kind of in a little
bit of heat because while it's never
been confirmed there are more than a few
people myself included who have a
suspicion that part of the reason season
8 of Game of Thrones felt as rushed as
it did both in terms of how quickly it
was wrapping up the narrative threads of
the show and also how short the season
was it was hard not to feel like they
just wanted to be done with it so they
could start working on other things like
this Star Wars trilogy not that like
Star Wars they very obviously we're done
gamezone's the one to do other stuff
that was just the thing that they had
lined up next
now this trilogy is now not happening
and apparently it was already being
pared down to where they were going to
produce all three but we're only going
to script one but as we learn more about
this then leaving this has apparently
been in the work for a couple of months
basically everyone knew they were gonna
leave it was a matter of getting the
contract sorted out so everybody could
walk away so they managed to tick off
Kathleen Kennedy and the folks over at
Lucasfilm by signing a massive deal with
Netflix which honestly I would say
Lucasfilm were well within their rights
to be ticked off about that these guys
no matter what you think about Game of
Thrones or how it turned out they've
only have that's their only major
project that they've done is running him
now Game of Thrones was major but it was
one thing and they were and they signed
on to this other thing that basically
meant they were going to be trying to
bring in new Star Wars movies and
executing this massive deal with Netflix
that they just ain't and Gloomsville
basically said there's no way you're
gonna devote everything you need to for
the Star Wars thing to work what are you
doing and so they wanted to get rid of
them also apparently word is that but I
often whites also kind of wanted out be
for a combination of reasons now this is
a little bit hearsay and I'm I don't
want to put too much weight on it and
sometimes I'm iffy about rumors but this
is corroborating stuff to what we know
for a fact which is they're not doing
that trilogy anymore that's a fact
that's not a rumor that's a definite so
some of the stuff I'm gonna mention
about that or rumors are just some of
the possible factors that may have been
part of this so I mentioned already
Lucasfilm being ticked at them them
wanting out so what it looks like is a
couple things the first is is that they
there is word that the creative field is
kind of restrictive over there right now
and or at least that is the environment
that people feel because it's probably
largely fueled by the fact that
well several people have been removed
from projects or had or had to heavily
rework them on the say-so of Lucasfilm
and Kathleen Kennedy the big ones being
rogue one which will underwent massive
reshoots and of course solo and then
there's also the fact that Colin
Trevorrow was removed from episode 9
there was also earlier josh trank and
the whole Boba Fett movie thing but I'm
not sure you could actually blame
Lucasfilm for that josh trank imploded
on himself so I don't think that's down
to Lucasville but right now they have a
track record of dropping directors and
in some cases still finishing the
project but even after they've ditched
the director so it doesn't come across
right now as a director friendly studio
in terms of oh come on over we'll let
you do what you want in our sandbox more
of a come on over here are the plans for
the different sand castle you can build
build one of those oh we kind of want to
do are they build one of these so and
again that's not fully corroborated but
um I I would say that at least being
concerned that that was the vibe given
the track record of directors being let
go or forced to do massive reshoots and
how many times that's happened in a
fairly short time period at the very
least even if that isn't the environment
you can't blame anybody for feeling that
it kind of looks like that from the
outside but then in addition to that huh
I think Benioff and Weiss really did not
know how badly received the last season
of Game of Thrones was gonna be and I
would not be surprised at all if they
looked at what happened with that the
fan reaction to that the heat they have
taken and continue to take for that and
then look at the current state of the
Star Wars fandom and kind of look at
each other and go are we about to
voluntarily march through a minefield
because it feels like that's what we're
about to do so you know again whatever
you feel about the current state of Star
Wars the fandom is very
riled up how about we go with that
there's a lot of fans with a lot of
metaphorically sharpened knives no
sharpened metaphorical knives it's not
like they have real knives that were
sharpened metaphorically the knives are
metaphor at least I hope they're
metaphorical don't threaten people with
knives that that's that that is the
ultimate moral of this video thanks
everybody
ok moving on so yeah again you could see
why maybe they would want out given that
they're coming off a kind of a bad taste
from fandom reaction to the last thing
they did so that that's all at play now
the other part of the rumor which is
good like for everything else going on I
read this this part of what's sort of
leaking out I'm like oh I hope that's
the case cuz that's good which is that
there they had carved out a slot in 2022
for the first of these trilogies and
they're not moving any other projects
that are being developed right now
forward to fill that slot that is good
because it means they're not gonna force
a rush on something that was never
intended to be ready that quickly just
to fill the slot which i think is a
really smart move that would be a smart
move for anybody that's a really smart
move for Star Wars right now the last
thing they can afford to do is saturate
the market with undercooked stuff
because again you know regardless of
what you think of any of the specific
things that have come out so far if they
just keep cranking out annual Star Wars
films and the quality isn't there a yeah
I mean it's very rare for a film to lose
a year in development and be better for
it so yeah that's that that's a good
call now what's still in the works well
there's the stuff on Disney plus we got
the mandalorian coming out there was
trailer for that there's the obi-wan
series that's still in the works I
haven't heard anything for a while
on the Ryan Johnson trilogy that he was
supposedly getting to do that seems to
have gone very quiet not canceled though
which given that they were more than
happy to announce the cancellation of
this thing from from these two guys I I
would think that if they were going to
cancel it they would say so but then
again given the given what's going on
with the fandom maybe they they feel
like announcing a cancellation of ryan
johnson stuff it feels like stoking the
fires of the fandom given how divisive
last Jedi turned out to be I don't know
that's really speculation on my part but
hold on we're not done because
apparently there's another Star Wars
film and development with Kevin Feige
set to produce anyone else getting the
feeling that Disney is really leaning on
Kevin Feige right now going oh my god
you're like the one guy who can make all
the stuff that shouldn't work work
please help save us I mean look at this
the guys have been running the MCU since
its inception so he's been there from
day one recently he has been put in
charge of Marvel TV which was headed by
other people until earlier this year he
he continues to have creative input and
has to deal with Sony on the spider-man
films and now they want his input on a
Star Wars film I'm pretty sure that if
they could if they could offer him
enough money to have him actually take
over running these Star Wars franchise
they would do it I just I don't think
there are enough hours in the day I'm
not sure there's enough hours of the day
for him to do all the things he's
already doing but props to the man he
runs a tight ship in a well-oiled
machine which right now the Star Wars
franchise is not and another thing
that's come out in the leaks is for all
the shifting around this going on
there's still no word of Kathleen
Kennedy being removed from heading the
studio and I don't know what to feel
about her one way or the other anymore
because
at this point so backtracking slightly
to my older stuff I I said before solo
came out regardless of whether the final
product is actually good that script
needed to be excellent because Kathleen
Kennedy basically steak told her ability
to measure creative output and final
product on the strength of that strip
because if you remember what was going
on with solo that had a script that she
and other executives loved they handed
it to Gordon Miller who started to
direct it
but because Lord and Miller are very
improv improvisational guys they were
rewriting on the fly and winging it and
you know they were gonna find it as they
shot in in the Attic because that's the
way these guys work and when the
Kathleen Kennedy and other executives
found that out they said no we have to
defend we have to protect this script
because it's so good so I knew going
into solo this script had better be
really good even if the final product
isn't great it better fall down on you
know acting or directing or visuals or
something the script better be
bulletproof because otherwise she kicked
out two really creative people in order
to save a script that wasn't very good
and that calls her judgment into
question when it comes to quality
material and the script fir'd solo
wasn't that good it wasn't awful it
wasn't bad but it was the kind of script
that executives liked because it ties
into all this other stuff and sets up a
bunch of things for later sequels
it was franchise made she loved it for
the same reason the Warner Brothers
executives loved Batman V Superman in
this in the studio screening because
they saw all the ways that it connected
at all the synergy but that doesn't make
it a good movie didn't make Batman V
Superman a good movie and it didn't make
solo a good movie but that's the kind of
stuff that executives love and again
Kevin Feige is very unique as an
executive because he seems to have an
understanding that yeah you can have
that stuff in that engine
but you have to look past that and still
have a good core product which solo
wasn't again it wasn't bad but it was
just kind of bland and there so I know
there are lots of very rabid fans or
like no she's pushing an agenda I don't
have an that's not my concern with her
my concern is she's exerting such tight
control over the creative process and I
don't trust her on the creative side
like it's one thing to remove a director
or to replace them because the budgets
out of control because you know they've
been shooting for months and have like
three scenes worth of usable stuff
that's a perfectly valid business reason
to fire a director but the fire a
director because you don't like the way
they're the direction they're taking it
creatively you need to kind of have your
own creative bona fides in line and she
doesn't she's a business person and she
may be of a good business person I don't
know enough about her background to be
able to say one way or another but she's
making the kinds of decisions about the
way these movies get done and which ones
get made and who gets to make them that
only somebody with a stronger instinct
for the creative end and the final
product should be making and she has not
demonstrated that she has that so
between the level of control that she's
exerting and the the lack of an
understanding of what these final
products should be and I'm not even
talking like you know the the last Jedi
did things that I don't like I'm just
saying she seems to have a very rigid
idea in her head about exactly what
these things should be and if the
directors deviate they get booted so I'm
not sure I trust that but we'll see it
is a bit of a mess right now and it'll
be it'll be it's gonna be weird to see
Rises Skywalker if I'm being completely
honest but really once that thing is out
other than
the mandalorian we don't have a very
clear picture of what is going on with
Star Wars and maybe that's a good thing
maybe the upside of the chaos is Star
Wars will actually take a break which I
suppose feeds into my being very glad
that things like Kevin Feige is probably
prodded project didn't get moved up to
fill that 2022 slot because yeah
everything seems to be a mess and maybe
what's in the best interest of everybody
is to just cool their heels for a bit
and sit down and really get this sorted
out because right now it seems like
they're flying by the seat of their
pants but think they have a plan and
either one is a naught is a viable
option you can wing it or you can
meticulously plan it but what you can't
do is wing it while believing you have
while behaving as if you meticulously
planned it which is what it feels like
right now so that's my thoughts on the
mess of Star Wars production right now
again not even talking about the nares
the production end of these things have
been a mess what do you think about any
of this whatever your thoughts are drop
something down in the comments let's
talk about it if you want to help me out
and keep this thing going and ensure
that I can eat why not check out my
patreon link down below plus there's a
link to other channels that I run
including sort of a secondary channel
for this called break room of geeks
there's a link to that like subscribe
share this video that helps grow the
channel as well so there's all that
stuff buttons things click links do it
or don't you don't have to because at
the end of the day you're the council
I'm just running the meetings and until
next time this council is adjourned
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]